now not long ago portland oregon was
hailed as the model city
proof that radical progressives could
create a wealthy urban utopia albeit
with a hippie granola sort of vibe to it
lefty comics even created an entire tv
show called portlandia remember that
that was showered with accolades for its
depiction of portland as a quirky fun
little city run by friendly vegans and
environmentalists
and remember all those keep portland
weird signs and t-shirts
well maybe they should focus on keeping
portland safe instead
according to portland police they
responded to 110 shootings just last
month that's about four shootings a day
even more alarming is almost 85 percent
of shootings this year have been in
north and east portland city and county
leaders are still scrambling to slow the
gun violence but so far community
members have not seen any results i
don't know you know exactly what the
answer is but i know that one thing is
it's harder now when you when you call
the police it takes longer to get here
the city has now passed a grim milestone
a record 67 homicides this year which
follows last year's 83 percent spike in
homicides now portland now has more
murders than bigger western cities like
san fran and seattle
and we must never forget that this
violence did not occur in a vacuum
it took root after oregon democrats made
it clear that it considered president
trump a bigger threat to portland than
the radicals who were occupying entire
city blocks and setting fires
their forces are not needed here they
are not wanted here and they're making a
challenging situation worse the protests
in portland have been
overwhelmingly peaceful
crime in portland
and across oregon
was down
before donald trump sent in a secret
police these guys came in like a
bulldozer it's a disaster the
administration's own making
oh please democrats are the ones who
created the disaster and it is a deadly
one now who knows how many lives were
lost and damage was done after they cut
27 million dollars from the police
budget just last year
and earlier this year the state passed
what is in effect
pro rioter legislation
banning police from using force against
them and charging violators with only
second-degree official misconduct
now meanwhile portland liberals were
coddling and encouraging the marxist
revolutionaries who were attacking
police officers and putting the city to
the torch
there is violence and there is
destruction what's your message to the
people on the streets tonight
my message is you've been heard thank
you for calling out the administration
for what it's doing it's
unconstitutional it's an affront to
democracy
now this only of course demoralized the
police since august 2020 nearly 200
portland police officers have left the
force
now the police are so under man they
can't even enforce routine traffic
violations and they can't they certainly
don't have the numbers to keep rampant
homelessness in check
but have no fear because oregon governor
kate brown and friends are focused on
thwarting the real threat
right-wing violence in august they wrote
the threatened use of violence against
people in the destruction of property to
further bigoted political or social
objectives undermines our growing
commitment to a truly inclusive
community
we're committed to working together to
keep our community safe and counter
dangerous efforts to undermine democracy
but when antifa committed 500 000 in
damage last week in the city's downtown
area
did any of those democracy protectors
condemn it
of course not
they don't care
because they'll say anything to maintain
power and control no matter how
devastating to their constituents
emery taskin and his wife yashim are
living in a nearly constant state of
anxiety their business has been
vandalized or broken into the windows
shattered four times so far during the
pandemic in total since march 2020 we
spent almost twenty thousand dollars for
all these people who are doing this they
feel really comfortable while doing that
they feel like nothing is going to
happen
no response will come as quick
now this is all kind of the sad final
predictable act of everything liberal
democrats touch
from detroit to oakland now portland
this reign of terror always ends with
lawlessness an accident exodus
and of course death
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else